the Tea Party came to Washington today
to deliver a message to congressional
Republicans don't compromise I'm not
talking about five billion or six
billion or ten billions I'm talking
about 100 billion thing yeah I'm more
that is discarded the Tea Party is made
up of thousands of loosely aligned
groups around the country with one
shared goal cutting the size and
influence of government spending money
you shouldn't tell you so a politician
the money is ready to take worthless
seconds it hasn't happened yet going
backwards they were a powerful force in
last November's election senators Marco
Rubio Mike Lee and Rand Paul are just a
few of the freshman politicians who owe
their victories to the tea party tonight
there's a tea party tidal wave and we're
sending a message to them while many tea
party groups strive to make themselves
heard in Washington in Ohio there's a
new focus local politics if you can't
elect a township trustee or a school
board member how you can elect the
President United States the Ohio liberty
Counsel is an umbrella organization of
65 Tea Party and other activist groups
from around the state in March had held
an all-day strategy meeting at The Ohio
State University campus we have a unique
responsibility Ohio I mean it just has
to be clear to everyone this is where
the fate of our nation will be decided
so you need to take that responsibility
seriously you're going door to door to
your neighborhoods your members are
talking to their neighbors and they're
trusting you to have good advice to
vetted candidates and to have a reason
to back somebody and then they're going
to vote for that trustee they're going
to vote for that school board member
they're going to vote for that Mayor
they can revoke that city council member
your neighbor as a conversation with you
and it's very substantive there's
nothing more powerful than that
conversation all of our focus is going
to be state-based because we feel that
DC is just it's not going to go to many
places too fast right now we wanted to
create smaller groups and not have one
large Columbus tea party but have
several smaller groups eventually break
those down into neighborhoods have block
captains so if any message needed to get
out send it out to one person they had
no 10 people on the street and therefore
we can start
that way you saw a 2 to three percent
bump for them relative to how they did
in the rest of the county we're putting
together a designated contact in every
federal congressional district and every
state house in state senate district
across the state of ohio and you've seen
the effect of that a good example is
Senate bill 5 here in Ohio which is
collective bargaining reform for public
unions to key senatorial votes flipped
because of the pressure we were able to
bring Ohio has at least one local
politician with an outsized influence on
the national stage that's house speaker
john boehner as GOP minority leader
under george w bush boehner
rubber-stamped almost every initiative
to expand the scope and size of the
federal government Speaker Boehner lives
about half a mile from my house he lives
he goes to our church he's a member of
our church I haven't ever seen him there
but every couple of weeks we meet with a
member of his staff we sit down we have
drinks and we talk about this is what
we're hearing from our members one of
our biggest issues the last time we met
was on the debt ceiling that they're
going to try to raise in the next next
couple of weeks i think in april they
need to raise the debt ceiling again and
we really really strongly oppose the
raising of the debt ceiling so our next
step is to call that's the call the
donors mr. boehner and just say you know
you've been a supporter of mr. boehner
in the past not i'm not sure if you
support him on this issue the sole
purpose of a political party is to get
someone elected that's it George Bush's
presidency got me involved the Tea Party
the Patriot Act and Medicare Part D
coming to debate and then close you know
as you had a Republican Congress kind of
doing all these things that were really
just you know what I considered horrible
legislation that's why they don't care
what that Republican believes once your
Republican their job is to get that
person elected and that frustrates us I
use this term on a pragmatic libertarian
I could probably come to common ground
with people between you know half and
all the time it's not a monolithic view
of anything the most important issue for
me personally is Second Amendment rights
that doesn't mean that I don't work on
other things I believe that that a
marriage is between a man and a woman
and I believe that that marriage then
that vow in front of God does present
some
definitely some challenges but also some
benefit why we'll have the conversation
later just because it's pretty off topic
but we'll all have personal opinions you
know I may be one of those people all
I'm looking for with those individuals
who make up part of the Tea Party
movement all the part of the Tea Party
movement that are on that Christian
right where do we share common ground
because fiscal issues are agnostic
anyone can join you two plus two equals
four in any language and anywhere under
earth is equals to pursue goals for if
we stick to that the social issues will
take care of themselves this cannot be
done from any kind of the top of a
pyramid it has to be citizen engagement
that is you dealing with your local
areas first and taking the stand in your
backyard Tea Party movement hasn't done
anything that's been oh my gosh we've
changed American politics permanently
the world is a better place know what it
did a really good job of doing was
changing a narrative it opened up a very
common conversation for America talk
about you know the three big things we
focus on a limited government fiscal
responsibility and free markets so the
fact that that conversation hadn't been
had so long and that this sort of
populist uprising called the Tea Party
helped to make that happen great though
I don't I have no expectation of
anything coming out of Congress that's
going to be very close to what I would
like to see happen but we can't have a
greater degree of effect at the state
level and that's where we're hoping to
play a really really big role